he's Charlie ever saw he's one of the
cofounders of the new spring football
league and he joins us on the program
good morning Charlie how's morale
fabulous how are you I'm doing great
tell me how you came up with the name of
this spring football league we were
talking about what our core belief was
and ultimately what we focused on was
this alliance and aligning players fans
and football that in if you look at
players and the league's and fans and
the league's and media and the league
there are always separate entities well
what would happen if you align them what
if what would happen if instead of a
commissioner you put an executive and a
player at the very top of this together
you'd create an alliance and the name
naturally flowed out of there is this in
competition or in conjunction with the
NFL neither we see it as complementary
okay now do you can you come out of high
school and play in this league no we're
gonna follow the NFL's guidelines I
think the thing that we would never want
to see happen is a 16 17 year old kid
getting hit by a 25 26 year old man
developmentally physically we really
think the NFL is identified from a
safety perspective and health and
wellness something that should be
observed 18 League right now we you
haven't announced where those sights
were going to be what is it based on why
are we waiting my father told me when I
was young that if you have a good story
break it up into pieces and spread it
out don't give up all the goods and one
historian give me a morsel today Charlie
you're gonna be very happy damn you
personally will be very happy about who
who our coaches are and who our cities
aren't we're gonna start announcing next
month and if you were impressed and
hopefully you were by the people that
we've put together on that stage
yesterday you're gonna be very happy and
very impressed with who our head coaches
and cities are okay now that's not that
big of a hint here for me I'm thinking
about if you did a Pacific Northwest if
you did Portland if you did Birmingham
if you did you're gonna stay away from
NFL cities right does that make sense no
not necessarily
here's the thing we want to focus on we
want to focus
fan engagement you want to look at
places where look the thesis of this
league is that on February 5th there are
tens of millions of Americans that stop
watching professional sports and stop
playing fantasy altogether so where are
the pockets of people that are most
affected by football going off the air
in terms of their level of engagement
and other sports this is not sort of
putting our finger up in the air and
seeing which way the wind is blown we
really spent the last year-and-a-half
studying where we thought the
marketplace was and how we could best
take advantage of it will you embrace
gambling I think it's too early to say
about what where the world is going to
end up in that I mean we're gonna be the
first league in history to have fully
integrated fantasy which will allow to
allow fans for the first time ever to
play fantasy while they're playing the
game so when you want to you know like I
said yesterday nobody no fan watches a
professional sports game the way they
play fantasy who picks their player five
days before the play they think the
games going to rest on five days before
they do it while they're watching and
given that we're going to build this
Alliance app that people will be able to
watch games for free on while they're
watching it's fully integrated into the
video that you're going to be able to
play play to play will you compete with
the NFL for talent
no no that's ultimately what we see
ourselves as as think of it this way
professional soccer in the world right
you have the Premier League you have the
MLS et cetera they're not competing for
talent there's sharing there's people
that are playing on both sides they're
people that start in one place and end
up in another and vice versa we're an
independent organization we the thing
that I think is a massive misconception
about football is look at another
business look at look at a business that
is as dominant as the NFL is in a space
the way that the footballs dominate the
United States six times the number of
people watch a professional football
game then the next four professional
sports average game ratings combined but
yet they don't operate for six months of
the year so from a business perspective
I look at that and say okay there are
millions of people who exclusively watch
football and then they stop watching
professional sports because it goes off
the air so I'm just going to give the P
what they want I'm just gonna give it to
him in the highest quality that's ever
been done and certainly in the last
quarter century by putting real football
experts on the field so it's nice
thinking about the NFL as a competitor
is it's not applicable to the fact that
we're not operating in the same markets
give me the salary structure for these
teams it's single entities so every
player operates plays for the league is
contracted for the league and then the
players what we looked at more was we
want to take care of our players in
season and then obviously after the
season so the players will make their
base salary and then they will have this
bonusing structure that includes a win
bonus statistical bonuses and other
bonusing structure within the game that
both the players that we brought in
troit excuse me Troy Justin Hines and
the executives JK Bill etc felt in a
modern sports league would not only
incentivize players best but also reward
players best for what they were
committing to and then the last one is
what we're going to roll out over the
next couple of months which i think is
probably the most innovative side of our
player fan engagement is that we're
gonna have fan engagement bonuses and
what we look at is you know the social
relationship between a player and his
community both his community of fans his
his local hometown community his
community of other players etc it's
something that not only do we were on a
reward we want to galvanize and so what
we're gonna build in the structure of
players contracts is the ability to have
a multi-point 360 touch point with the
game their fans and their fellow players
we're talking to Charlie Ebersole he's
one of the cofounders the Alliance of
American football spring football debuts
in 2019 what did you learn from the XFL
that can help you well I would go beyond
that and just say what have I learned
from every attempt at putting football
on the field in February it's that you
got to put real football experts at the
top of it and let them put real football
on the field I mean this there are two
ways in which I would not have announced
if I hadn't spent the last year and a
half with one of the greatest team
builders of all time Bill Polian and if
I didn't
have a serious partner like CBS who not
only provided quality but the greatest
reach I mean talking about America's
number-one network for the better part
of a decade that those two things were
essential to ensuring that I was going
to put quality football in the field and
then secondarily you you have to have
people at every level we're both the
fans and the players feel like you're
making a real commitment and that you
are attempting to serve them in the best
possible way and so by creating this
structure where we don't have a
commissioner but we have JK McKay and
Troy Polamalu at the top in in equal
footing to build something meaningful we
really believe that they're going to be
represented diverse conversation and
they and I don't just mean gender or
racial or sexual or anything I mean
diverse in terms of really significant
different approaches to get to the same
place is extraordinarily important in
the modern era and for some reason it
hasn't happened to professional sports
yet how would the action on the field be
different well we're looking at plays
we're looking at changing plays where
either the fan engagement is low or
safety and so for example getting rid of
the kick off for two reasons one its
regularly considered one of the most
dangerous plays in professional football
but the second reason is because if you
look at almost any study of fans they
save the most boring play in a game is a
kickoff the least amount of stuff
happens it's least likely to produce
something interesting so we're getting
ready to kick off you're gonna start
with the ball in the 25 obviously if you
get rid of the kickoff you have to get
rid of the onside kick so what we're
doing is if you want to go for the
equivalent of an onside kick we will
give you your ball on the 35 on your own
35 and you'll be facing 4th and 10 if
you convert you keep going if you don't
as bill says you're giving the ball back
to someone knocking on your own red zone
so we look at those things we're getting
rid of the extra point we want people to
play on the field so they're gonna have
to go for two points and I think
something that you and I talked about a
long time ago in terms of speeding up
the game we're going to take the play
clock down to 30 seconds so you know it
reflects what's happening in the game
already I mean most NFL offenses are
getting to the line you know 17 20
seconds they don't need to fall the full
complement provided by the NFL in the
modern era you're partnering with CBS
CBS Sports Network
how many games will be televised each
week one game a week so the three
premiere on CBS the week after they have
the Super Bowl and then we are we have
one game week of CBS SN which will run
us through the regular season and then
the playoffs and the championship will
be on CB oh sorry the playoffs we on CBS
SM the championship will be on CBS the
last weekend of April who's the
commissioner we don't have a
commissioner that's one of the archaic
structures that I think we looked at and
decided we didn't want to have this is a
but Dan here's the thing right this is a
fundamental flaw I think in thinking
around professional sports professional
sports are naturally a partnership of
players and executives right you have
two groups that have to work in harmony
now one we eliminate that because we
have were a single entity structure so
the league ultimately is the corporation
so in doing so we didn't have to put
someone at the top of the league I'm
talking about the Football League so at
the top of the Football League JK McKay
and Troy Polamalu are on equal footing
and representing both the game and the
players Troy will have as much say and
how the game is being structured you
know in terms of the plays health and
safety cetera and JK equally on the
player set now it helps that they both
played professional football and both
sides of the ball and that they're both
entering the u.s. eSports Hall of Fame
this year which as a Notre Dame graduate
I'm still having trouble saying out loud
but we'll put that aside well they're
probably partially going in because of
their performance against Notre Dame
there Charlie hey by the way I got one
word for you for the Commissioner if you
if you decide to go Commissioner Gronk
[Music]
come join our party I never look that
man is the most dangerous tight end I've
ever seen in the game on the field off
the field on the field okay listen
oh let me tell you another thing about
professional sports I think that you got
to celebrate the players for what they
do on the field and then you got to look
at what they do in terms of the
community all joking aside about Gronk
he's got a big heart and he's taking
care of a lot of people you know people
people focus on that side of it but I
look I look at the players that we put
on the stage yesterday in terms of who
our partners are and you talk about the
Justin Tuck's and the Heinz wards and
the Troy Polamalu
of the world and the Jared Allen's these
are guys who not only had phenomenal
careers on the field but look at the
lives they built afterwards not just
their own but the communities that they
supported I mean Justin Tuck is
supporting communities in New York
Oakland South Bend and Alabama all at
the same time that's the epitome of what
we want to build we want and at the same
time we want guys who are fun you Grunk
is ready to come play in our league
we're excited to have Grunk did you hear
from the NFL
I mean look given the people that we
have involved at the top of this
obviously we are having conversations
Evan when I first started researching
this I was not shy about talking to the
NFL as well as the NBA and the NCAA and
every other group that I had
relationships with at the top of Anna
builded to really understand why they
make certain decisions why they think
the way that they do I mean I think that
one of the things that's super important
to understand about what we're trying to
do here is we're taking a holistic
approach because we're not building a
one or two year business certainly our
goal is to build a seven to ten year
business because you don't really know
if a business is real or not in the
first 24 months
it's a ridiculous way to actually think
about building businesses and so the
measurement of what we believe in is
that we're looking at years five six
seven as the core focus charlie good
luck 2019 the Alliance of American
football thanks man
thanks for having me on all right we'll
follow up with you Charlie Charlie ever
saw four more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
you
[Music]